Nos dicen: "Mueve el punto anaranjado a 3.39 en
la recta numérica". Aquí comienzo con 3 enteros
2 décimas y aquí, en este otro extremo, tengo 3
enteros 5 décimas, esto quiere decir que entre
estos dos hay 3 décimas. Por otra parte vemos
que la recta está dividida en 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19,
20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, en 30
partes iguales; si tengo 3 décimas divididas en 30
partes iguales quiere decir que cada diez marcas
es una décima, que están señaladas aquí con la
raya más grande. Aquí tengo 3 enteros 2 décimas,
aquí estará 3 enteros 3 décimas, aquí 3 enteros
4 décimas y, bueno, aquí 3 enteros 5 décimas.
Entonces cada décima está dividida en diez partes
iguales, pero ¿qué representan estas partes? Cada
la rayita es una décima de una décima, esto es
lo mismo que una centésima. Entonces nos piden
3 enteros 39 centésimas, quedamos que comenzamos
con 3 enteros 2 décimas, y 2 décimas es lo mismo
que 20 centésimas. Aquí hay 3 enteros 3 décimas o
3 enteros 30 centésimas, y de estas 30 centésimas
comenzamos a contar 31 centésimas, 32 centésimas,
33, 34, 35, 36, 37, 38 y 39 centésimas. Esta es
la marca que nos interesa, aquí debemos colocar
nuestro puntito anaranjado. Vamos a comprobar
la respuesta, y es correcta. Resolvamos otra
pregunta: "Mueve el punto anaranjado a 9.04 en
la recta numérica". Ésta se ve interesante.
Aquí comenzamos con 8 enteros 9 décimas y
terminamos con 9 enteros 1 décima. La recta
está dividida como en el ejercicio anterior,
cada décima en diez partes iguales, de manera que
esta raya más grande indica 9 enteros 0 décimas,
y aquí tenemos 9 enteros 1 décima. Ahora nos están
pidiendo 9 enteros 4 centésimas, ¿dónde están las
centésimas? Si cada décima, esta es una décima
y esta es otra, está dividida en uno, dos, tres,
cuatro, cinco, seis, siete, ocho, nueve, diez
partes iguales -lo mismo acá-, significa que cada
rayita es la décima parte de 1 décima, es decir,
1 centésima; cada décima está dividida en 10
centésimas, cada rayita pequeña es 1 centésima. Si
aquí tenemos 9 enteros 0 décimas, o 0 centésimas,
vamos a contar las centésimas o las rayitas
pequeñas: aquí hay 1 centésima, 2 centésimas, 3
centésimas, 4 centésimas. Aquí están los 9 enteros
y 4 centésimas, movemos nuestro puntito acá,
comprobamos que nuestra respuesta es correcta.
Y una vez que tenemos la respuesta correcta,
no nos hace ningún daño ver las pistas que nos
dan. Por ejemplo: "Arriba hemos trazado la recta
numérica desde 8.9 hasta 9.1, dividida en 20
partes iguales". Esta sección está dividida en
diez y esta otra sección también está dividida
en diez partes iguales, en total tenemos veinte
partes iguales. Veamos la siguiente pista: "La
recta está dividida en 20 partes, lo que significa
que:" si yo tomo esta cantidad, 9.1, y la resto
a la de aquí, 8.9, y esto lo divido entre 20,
me va a dar que cada división es igual a 1
centésima. Esta es otra forma de decir que
cada raya pequeña es 1 centésima. Los invito a que
vean las pistas después de resolver el ejercicio
y traten de comprenderlas y compararlas con lo
que ustedes hicieron. Veamos la siguiente pista:
si partimos de que lo que queremos encontrar,
9.04 = 8.9 -esta cantidad con la que iniciamos-,
más nuestros incrementos de 0.01 x 14, quiere
decir que tuvimos que movernos 14 lugares para
posicionar este puntito, por lo tanto, hay que
mover el punto anaranjado 14 lugares para llegar
a la posición 9.04. Vamos a hacer otro problema.
"Mueve el punto anaranjado a 5.93 en la recta
numérica". Vemos que iniciamos en 5.7 y terminamos
en 6.0, y de nuevo tenemos aquí estas marcas,
quiere decir que esta raya grande marca 5.7,
esta 5.8 y esta 5.9, hay 3 décimas: aquí,
aquí hay una décima y aquí hay otra décima, y cada
una de ellas está dividida en diez partes iguales,
o lo que es lo mismo en 10 centésimas. Nos piden
poner el punto anaranjado en 5.93. Estas 7 décimas
también podemos verlas como 70 centésimas, lo
que nos conviene porque el problema está en
términos de centésimas; en esta marca tenemos 8
décimas u 80 centésimas, y aquí tenemos 9 décimas
o 90 centésimas. A partir de estas 90 centésimas
vamos a contar las rayas pequeñas hasta llegar a
93 centésimas: 90, 91, 92 y 93, aquí es donde va a
estar este punto anaranjado. Vamos a comprobar la
respuesta, es correcta, y vamos a ver de nuevo las
pistas que nos dan aquí. La primera pista dice:
"Arriba hemos trazado una recta numérica desde
5.7 hasta 6.0, dividida en 30 partes iguales".
Nosotros encontramos tres secciones, indicadas por
las rayas grandes, y cada una de ellas dividida en
diez secciones, indicadas por las rayas pequeñas,
que nos da treinta partes iguales. Siguiente
pista: "La recta está dividida en 30 partes, lo
que significa que:" esta cantidad menos esta otra,
dividido entre estas treinta secciones es igual
a 0.01, o lo que es lo mismo 1 centésima. Vamos
viendo las siguientes pistas. Aquí resuelven la
operación, donde el punto que nos piden es igual
al punto inicial más 1 décima multiplicada por 23,
e incluso nos están marcando el valor en donde se
encuentran las décimas, y aquí nos indican en
donde debemos colocar el punto. Yo espero que
esto haya sido útil, y los invito a que vayan
a la plataforma y realicen estos ejercicios.